se tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
nuovo video sarò fa vj oggi siamo su sto
regolando queste cose come se avessi
acceso la macchina fantastico mi sento
un pilota di formula 1 oggi l'america e
quindi siamo su è più il se la cosa che
non ho mai detto nella mia vita una
frase proprio nuova e detto questo direi
che possiamo cominciare con la prima
sigman poco fa sempre paura leggeresti
nomi e poi vedere che bello infatti mi
sembrava che cosa dalla stiva scatta un
attimo fammi capire se nei prodotti
estate te la cavi bene 0 non c'è dubbio
su questo che narrava ti passa morendo
da solo perfetto ok ma cosa devo fare
qua sai a madonna ma non è una falce
quella un cazzo di di bazooka stato
misto inglobando una falsa come se fosse
una gnocca e bellissima sa cosa bravo
steam
e intanto il tizio le fa le pippe al
manico fantastico stranissima la madonna
minchia che che mai e la [ __ ] ragazzi
ha fatto è un combattimento senza
precedenti e belli ma va là come è
rimasto il tizio davanti bellissimi se
importo la spina dorsale zio questo ha
leggermente mancato il bersaglio ma ok
abeti vecchia amica sui [ __ ]
forse si è fatto male ma forse è stata
una cosa è la madonna che stecca no
cazzo ma preso non sono morto però mi ha
staccato le gambe vabbè boss è la
madonna che grosso è caduto male su cade
careca decade è appreso col pene ragazzi
mi ha preso col pene e sono morto mica
che corsa che cosa prova schivata dovuto
schivare cazzo ho perso un piede ma
vabbè se non scarpe nuove questa ragazza
un passato da foot locker prima e l'ho
preso che belle scarpe ragazze non mi
servono eccolo lì vai così a piedi nudi
senza i piedi proprio che nell adesso
cade che adesso la scarpa ti piace la
scarpata regalo guarda te la regalo ma
prima me ne vado a [ __ ] ce l'ho fatta
incredibile ragazzi ce l'ho fatta senza
i piedi perché in fondo ragazzi piedi
non servono un cazzo via così finto non
so come non voglio sapere niente alto il
suo livello è stato abbastanza strano
farlo melle cipro
cos'è sta roba con enti snoop dogg ma
cosa
non rende tanto vero mi fa strano
ok sono stato ucciso da un pacco di
patatine e e che le foglie patatine
fanno male non era uno scherzo cioè non
era uno scherzo quando me lo dicevano
madonna quel cappellino che ho scritto
sul web tra ma è bellissimo
questo livello più bello della storia
caduta una playstation 4 gli occhiali da
mlg la canna illuminati c'è di tutto
questo livello bellissimo complimenti
per il livello di è più il più figo che
abbia mai visto nella mia vita è stata
un'esperienza proprio incredibile grazie
di questa perla del fan lo scazzo vuol
dire punk ora questo sfondo verde
bruttissimo mi dicono che lì
e vabbè cassonati un complimenti a
livello più tranquillo del mondo insomma
giocherà flipper bello po più su ancora
un po andava niente ciò che è accaduto
non cogliate
un'emozione che parte proprio da dentro
mi viene da esprimerla proprio dopo aver
giocato a questo livello
wow che bello siamo il save your song
che mister mi piace un casino fa sta
roba perché non becco mai
come cazzo fatto non lo so neanche io
cosa fa si muove lo stesso sei morto zio
non vinco maya sta roba
vabbè è successo mi a me ne farò una
ragione spagnolo spyphone neanche questo
riesco mai vediamo se stavolta è la
volta buona proprio anche se ne dubito
proprio infatti mi sembrava troppo bello
per essere vero iniziato a fare i
livelli a vincerli subito orca merda ma
che sfiga cioè oggi non so cosa mi è
preso ma sono abbastanza abbastanza
stronzo lo sai e di ghetto [ __ ] segue
è l'ultimo the che sono andato a los
angeles non so che sei incazzato ma me
ne frega un cazzo
ho vinto ho vinto ho vinto voglio le
medaglie subito grazie magari anche un
po di colla non so se serve bedroom
vento l'avventura della stanza da letto
ragazzi non avevo idea plessiva
l'happening bedogni essere bello 10 su
10 il livello più bello della mia vita
complimenti cioè io salvare l'amico a
livello un livello che esprime della non
ho mai fatto il livello del genere la
prima volta e giuro
wow è stato molto difficile ragazzi
basta co sti cazzo di a domino cose
domino non posso fare ma veramente come
fa ma no ho scelto l'unico pirla col
quale non possa arrivare al bottone
fantastico dyck e spingi spingi ma come
tutti quelli che potevo scelto con
annuncia che cazzo tie dye vice ma no
suo detto strangio bravo spinge nord da
parte bravo bravo cazzo no no no no no
no me la dai
e allora sei stronzo no vabbè sarà al
livello più difficile della storia ma ci
devo riuscire me ne frega niente dai
cribbio da devi andare su ciò che non è
più bravo bravo bravo bravo veloce no
preferivo giocare
mario ma credetemi che ha una sede fitch
e dai porca merda sì sì cazzo ce l'ho
fatto ragazzi è stato alquanto difficile
mettiamo così ok go into the room
non sono andato nella stanza ma ok va
bene così perfetto è stato difficile
dovevo premere un bottone e non ci stavo
riuscendo perfetto poi highlights freddi
su world trovo cos'è starò anno boltro
scusate non so neanche leggere
fantastico cosa vuol dire che se becca
una roba sbagliato a becco freddi abello
sono morto africa muoiono nel 90 per
cento dei casi perché ci sono un
miliardo di robe tra vabbè ma è
impossibile vincere la star o brega
golden freddy's ed ho beccato la testa
di golden frey che bella dov'è la
vittoria
dove è la vittoria sempre avanti alla
chiave casa pronti alla chioma good and
ho vinto perfetta e mi dispiace con la
testa di freddi ma oggi ho vinto così
gta san andreas
fold space to start fatemi vedere cos'è
sta roba sei serio nel figata ed 8 degli
al triangle formando ragazzi e
bellissima sta cosa non lo so io sì j
gusti lo ha fatto in tempo a leggere
vabbè hawkinson ballast oh mio dio è la
madonna che cazzo è un bazooka ma
veramente posso usare ste cose
chi è che ha fatto sta voglio le
medaglie up che piovono ma [ __ ] a
crepa in realtà ragazzi è morto solo che
non vuole darlo a vedere
e finito così ma che ho mani che mi sto
prendendo benissimo d'accordo che anzi
faccio un paio di miei livelli perché
ancora non da un pezzo che non faccio
questa roba mi avranno mandato tante
cristo nate che la metà bassa fa vj la
nutella con 2t nutella ti prego fai
questo livello e ti prego smetterà di
ragazzi a giornata col turismo sole mio
video ciao bello al alla si chiama super
la cia la alla grazia e nutella si
scrive con una t però ok nutella si è
corretta ragazzi e corretta andiamo
dietro che c'è la nutella dietro dai è
di casa un po di sfidando se vogliamo la
nutella
ma cosa lo sta facendo la madre coi
figli cosa fa queste cose sporchi in
pubblico
babbo non ancora fini cosa vuol dire
come faccio che ho solo un baratto ma
che ora c'è un buon natale che si è
potuto la nutella bastardo è sempre un
giorno di merda quando babbo natale ti
fotte la nutella ragazzi c'è una roba
normale
e vabbè è stata l'unica a l'unico modo
l'unico modo per farlo è l'asta era
questo praticamente ok
voglio la nutella spingi qui a c'è un
coso ma non come faccia spinge non c'è
niente c'è steve che è morto e depresso
proprio la nutella sono depressi michele
guardano come depresso che dondola pure
allora li mortacci sua va beh non
importa basta che spingi spingi spingi
come sapeva ma [ __ ] fa vj verso
sfrutta solo tu puoi battere la frutta
prima che sia troppo da amico mio che
problemi hai infami capire cosa vuol
dire poi battere la frutta cosa tipo
fruit ninja
ok non ho mai visto della frutta
assassina cioè della frutta che vuole
uccidermi con un'ascia ragazzi buttati
che è morbida amico io ma che cazzo sei
di problemi fa vj quiz fa vj mancino
destro che il destro ma io l'ho già
visto il traguardo quindi allora
ascoltami dio prima di fare un livello
la prossima volta pensaci due o tre
volte che è poi lo fai perché no proprio
no ok fa vj verso sud la nuova gara
mortale contro fa vj come il nuovo
personaggio cos'è cosa koichi eque cosa
dovrebbe mai essere quella roba ragazze
io sarei quello ragazzi cos'è non è
possibile
datemi sono scarsissimi mi ci voleva una
merda sa bene per pensavo di vincere
almeno io non sono morto prima ma se le
paure come vada in guerra come faccio lo
sborone l'impennata fanta bravo zio
bravo fai vedere chi sei fai vedere
chiede no ma sei andarci in bici e farvi
i complimenti ragazzi magari se mettiamo
alla rotella sto povero cristiano che
non sa andare ancora in bici tipo
vent'anni bravissimo come è così che va
in bici è bravo porta in alto il nome di
famiglia i complimenti e carico e che
tutto lui mi ha bloccati che mi ha
bloccato lascia zio complimenti sono
anche un genio ho vinto ho vinto
importante che io abbia vinto non so
come ho fatto a rialzarmi da terra ma ok
comunque ragazzi conclude l'episodio se
anche voi credete di andare in bici
meglio di come ci vado io che non è che
ci voglia molto è però ok lasciato mi
piace fatemelo capire così dovrò tirare
fuori quella cazzo di pc prima o poi
puoi vedere che cazzo succede
spero che video vi sia piaciuto e cosa
hai da ragazzi servito è piaciuto
lasciato momento mi piace anche la
voglia di facebook e come ogni video ha
trovato una descrizione se non sapresti
destinazioni ci dividiamo prossimo
vinitaly stava ammazzando però va beh
beh ragazzi